big investment Banks and money managers
didn't get much right in their
predictions for 2023 most were betting
on a recession rate cuts from the
Federal Reserve and a middling Year from
the US Stock Market instead the S&P 500
gained nearly 25% the FED raised rates
and the US economy grew at the fastest
Pace in years so what are the big Banks
betting on in 2024 I'm going to tell you
what Wall Street is predicting for the
economy what they're expecting from the
fed and how they're expecting the stock
market to perform this year let's get
into
it more than 2third of the economists at
large financial institutions that do
business directly with the FED said they
expected the us to have a recession in
2023 we detailed a couple of the
recession predictions on this channel
some analysts are saying that the
recession that most of Wall Street
predicted would hit this year hasn't
been avoided it's just been delayed but
it didn't happen and in 2024 recession
calls are few and far between among
economists and Market forecasters most
big Banks expect the US economy to grow
by around 2% in line with its long-term
Trend city is one of the few big Banks
predicting a recession this year but
even they aren't predicting the stock
market will fall the bank is calling for
the S&P 500 to end 2024 just under 10%
higher than where it ended 2023 Deutsche
Bank is also predicting a US recession
this year the firm says the effects from
the fed's unprecedented rate hiking
cycle in 2023 will bring about a mild
recession this year but they're also
predicting that you US Stocks Rise by
nearly
10% most big banks are predicting the
FED will be cutting interest rates this
year a few believe it's because the us
will have a recession but most are
predicting that with inflation falling
below 3% at the end of 2023 it will get
close to the fed's 2% Target this year
and that will mean that the US Central
Bank can lower interest rates to loosen
up the economy when the FED Cuts rates
it is historically given a boost to
stock and bond prices that's expected to
happen this year with most analysts
predicting positive stock
returns at the end of 20123 market
strategists predicted that the S&P 500
would rise to
5132 that's about 10% higher than where
the index closed the year according to
fax set that was based on a collection
of median Target price estimates for all
the companies in The Benchmark us stock
index the last survey of 2023 by Bank of
America Securities found that fund
managers were the most optimistic in any
month since January 2022 and the most
bullish on stocks since February 2022
some of the predictions for the best
market returns come from firms like fun
Strat and yardeni research which both
called for the US to avoid a recession
last year some of the lowest Market
expectations come from JP Morgan and
Morgan Stanley JP Morgan sees a
challenging backdrop for markets overall
and expects that companies will struggle
to increase their profits significantly
and Morgan Stanley is expecting an
increase in the number of companies
defaulting on their loans big picture
most banks see solid economic growth
lower inflation and higher stock prices
this year which sounds pretty good but
remember big bank's predictions for 2023
didn't exactly pan out so don't
sleep